What's up y'all? Welcome, welcome,
welcome. Tonight we have our first
Adventist who wants to step up to the
answering Adventism plate. Let's give
him a round of applause, shall we? Thank
you, sir. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you.
He is going to be giving his best pitch
from scripture for us on why Satan is
typified by the Leviticus 16 scapegoat.
For those that do not know, the
Adventist Church teaches that the
atonement is still going on. Now, they
don't mean the same thing by atonement
that we do. They kind of lump some
things in there that Christians uh do
not. Uh different discussion for a
different time. Maybe it will come up
tonight. Who knows? Um, but they still
think the atonement's going on. Christ
is still dealing with sin in a sanctuary
building up in heaven. And at a point in
the future, he will transfer the sins of
those who make it through the
investigative judgment onto Satan, who
is ultimately responsible for them. So,
it is a part of their broader
investigative judgment and sanctuary
doctrine, if you will. Here's how it'll
work. He will have up to 15 minutes, if
he needs that much, um, uninterrupted to
present his, again, best case from
scripture. And then we're going to
examine this afterward and see how it
holds up. Jonathan, welcome to the show.
You will or the timer rather.
The timer will start uh when you first
begin talking. So, let me get that going
here. Anything you'd like to share with
the audience, feel free to share. Um but
like I said, um once we're ready to go,
I'll let you know. and then once you
start talking um the timer will begin.
Anything that you'd like to share sir?
Okay.
Thank you so much for
um the great opportunity to share my
opinion on this skip good.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Um I don't need any Adventist book or
anything because as I grow up
and be um decided to become a follower
of Jesus Christ, I've learned my way
through from research of by researching
my information from external sources.
If the information is true, then I don't
need what Adventists are saying. It
doesn't really matter. the information
the information is so true. So let's go
let's go in and then look for
all right
um what the scapegoat is.
Yep. I will uh I'll bring up your
presentation here and like I said once
you begin talking sir I will start your
time and once you have one minute left I
will give an announcement that you have
one minute left. The floor is yours.
Okay.
Thank you once again. And um
um
today we'll be discussing about the
Levitical 16 verse 1-34.
a concept that has been placed in in
scripture to tell us the plan of God's
salvation and how he's going to deal
with sin and
um how are we going to be forgiven and
at the same time how he's going to sin
from the earth as we see um from
Leviticus 16 I'll just go through
uh
uh slide by slide so that will get a
concept.
Um first before we can we we go in we
have to know what atonement is.
Atonement is to to compensate for a
wrong we are that this is for this is
from a dictionary explanation.
We were unable to get satisfied from the
local stores and speciation and then
satisfaction
to make an amendment. So in other
concepts we can say an atonement is to
make the children of God one with their
father because sin was the one
preventing them from becoming one again
with Christ with God. So in order for
God to make atonement for us so that we
can we our sins can be forgiven and then
we becoming
we becoming his children again. He has
to what? Um make sacrifice for us and
atone for our sins and then we once our
sins have been forgiven then we can
become one with God again. Um
let's go on and then this is an online
uh this is chat GBT I check and then it
says in broader context without any
Bible explanation what what best way can
I understand atonement and it says that
it just is refers to the an act of
reconciliation making amend for a
wrongdoing or cause damage so let's go
on
so we can get this concept from
Levitical 16 and then once we go through
we will get to understand what 18 really
means. We have um um
these are summary of the scriptures that
I just took. So verse three it says that
iron shall come into the holy place with
the blood of a bull of a young bull as a
sin offering and of a ram as bent
offering. So the y bull and the y bull
is for sin offering and then the the ram
is for bent offering. And then verse
five it says that and he shall take from
the congregation of the children of
Israel two kids of goods as sin offering
and one ram as bent offering. So here we
have two h another animal
classification. One is for burnt
offering and then the other the two case
of gold are for sin offering.
So Aon shall make offer shall offer the
the bull as sin offering which is for
himself and make atonement for himself
and for his house. And then
um verse 7, he shall take the two goss
and present them before the Lord at the
door of the tabernacle of meeting.
Then Aaron shall cast lot for the two
go. One Lord for the Lord and the other
for the scapegoat.
The Lord is cast on the two go. One is
for the Lord. That is the Lord's good.
And then the other one is for Aazel, the
escape go. That one is not for the Lord.
And Aaron shall bring the two goals on
which the Lord's the Lord's lord fell
and offer it as sin offering. But the
goat on which the Lord fell to be the
scapegoat shall be presented alive
before the Lord to make atonement upon
it and let it go into the wilderness
into the wilderness.
Right? The good for us is is never
sacrificed. It has none of it blood,
none of it cackers or anything bent on
the altar of God. This goat is presented
alive and sent away and we should the
best way we can learn this is to these
are symbolic representation of the
actual realm of how God is going to deal
with sin.
So the other Bible translation that use
the word as is that instead of the
scapegoat we have the new American
standard version.
We also have the English standard
version and then we also have new
revised standard version. All of these
Bible versions they use the word aes
instead of the scapegoat. So we we all
know that instead of using scapegoat we
can use the word aes and is cool.
So the good for the Lord is offered as
sin offering but the good for Aazel is
not not for the Lord. Atonement is made
upon it and sent alive into the
wilderness. So and then we now go to
verse 11. and Aaron shall bring the bull
the bull of the sin offering which is
for himself and make atonement for
himself and for his household and shall
kill the the bull as a sin offering
which is for himself.
So the the the one some of the animals
are being used for Aaron and his family
and then the others are used for um the
the goat is used for the whole house of
Israel.
Then he shall kill the good of the sin
offering which is for the people of the
people. Bring it blood inside the veil.
Do with do with that blood as he did
with the blood of the bull and sprinkle
it on the mercy seat. And before this
the
and before the mercy seed he so he shall
make atonement for the holy place
because of the uncleanness of the
children of Israel and because of their
transgression for all their sins and so
he shall do for the tabernacle of
meeting which remain among them in the
midst of their uncleanness.
The main purpose of the atonement is to
clean the sins of the people and to
reconcile them to God. And the law and
the law's good was used to do the
atonement for their sins.
Then verse 17, there shall no be
there shall be no man in the terminical
of meeting when he goes into the he goes
into to make atonement in the holy place
until he comes out that he may make the
atonement for himself for his
household's end.
Now verse 18. And he shall go out to the
altar that is before the Lord and make
atonement for it and make and and shall
take some of the blood of the bull and
some of the blood of the gold and put it
on the horns of the altar. So we here we
learn that the the one of the good that
the which is for the Lord was used for
the atonement for the people. So the
other good is has nothing to do with the
the forgiveness of sin of the children
of Israel. It has its own purpose
because God is the one who supersedes
all these things.
Then he shall sprinkle some of the blood
on it with the finger seven times,
cleanse it and consecrate it from the
uncleanness of the children of Isa. And
then verse 19, and then he has when he
has made all he has made an end to the
atonement for the holy place, the
tabernacle of meeting and the altar, he
shall bring the live gold. Aaron shall
lay both his hands on the head of the
live goat, the live goat. confess over
it all the iniquities of the children of
Israel and all their transgression
concerning all their sins, putting them
on the head of the good, and shall send
it away into the wilderness by the hand
of
an able man or suitable man. The go
shall bear the iniquities
of the children of Israel.
All right.
So in other for so the good for us the
good is alive. It has is is never
killed. The conf
confess over it all the sins iniquities
and transgression of the children of
Israel are put on it putting them on the
head of the goat. The goat shall bear on
itself all their iniquities to an in
inhabitable land shall be released into
the wilderness.
So they are the point. So who is
so and asel is a is a fallen angel. How
do I come by that conclusion? These are
secular information. You can free
on information online. Whoever want to
know what asal means can just go and
then look for it there. So in my
dictionary I I had this
um explanation in the Bible the evil
spirit in the wilderness to which the
scapegoat was sent on the day of
atonement. So this is an evil spirit.
The other trans uh the other meaning of
it is here the the demo or the place in
the wilderness to which the scapegoat is
released in the day of atonement the
scapegoat itself.
So this is has nothing to do with God or
um Jesus Christ or anything. This has to
do with what? Um the evil spirit or uh
the demon.
Again, this this is a continuation from
uh
my Bible search uh my the name search
for Aazel. So in the Bible the name
Aazel a Hebrew word appears in
association with the scapegoat right
name presented a desolate place where
the scape goat bearing the sin of the
people was sent during the end of the
second temple. This association
as this was his association as a fallen
angel responsible for introducing human
to forbidden knowledge he made due to
helenization.
Right? So this is a fallen angel and has
nothing to do with u
um Jesus Christ.
So
um
through my search I also had this um uh
scapegoat right from the
so-cal
enoch
eno scrolls and then it says that eno
portray portrays as responsible for
people for teaching people to make
weapons and cosmetics for which
he was cast from heaven. The book of
Enoch
8123. I've never read that. I had
information here. And Aazel taught men
to make SW sws and knives and and show
them breastplate and make known to them
the metal the metals of the metals and
the act of working them.
Right? And then this is from the um
Apocrypha. And then um it also depict
Satan as falling
fall of the angel. The biblical sorry
located on mount
on Mount Hmon. So from here we can we
can deduce that Aazel represent Satan
and Satan was a fallen angel.
So from careful reading of scripture
from Levitical 16 and looking for words
and not just putting our own mind into
what scripture is trying to tell us, we
we realize that on the day of atonement
is concerned about the forgiveness of
sin of the people of Israel. Animals
that were used were sacrificed and were
killed. The blood is sprinkled on the
mercy seat.
And part two is that Aazel is a demon
and a fallen angel. Who is that fallen
angel? And the answer is Satan. The good
for Aazel is not killed. Satan is still
left free up to this day. And God
promised that he will destroy him in the
final day. And that's what scriptures is
teaching us. The animal is sent to the
wilderness and Satan is still left
there. Sin are kept on the head of the
good of
one minute.
All right. Sin is re reunited with Satan
because he is the he is the cause of
lawlessness
is from him reserved to be destroyed in
the last day.
So we cannot say we cannot uh why Christ
cannot be the scapegoat is that Jesus
Christ was what he died for our sin he
wasn't alive to do that he shed his
blood this good as blood was never shed
and as the name suggest the name
represent Satan and a demon because the
Bible specifically state that the gold
is for a So it is it is illogical to say
that Jesus Christ the son of God is the
the devil or as
Thank you.
All right my man. Thank you. So with
that said, let's do some inspection on
this. Um so you said well a couple of
your your primary points. Um, let's
start with this. Leviticus 16:5. I I'll
bring it up here because I have a E
sword.
So Leviticus 16:5
says,
so you mentioned this, and he shall take
from the congregation of the people of
Israel two male goats for a sin offering
and one ram for a burnt offering.
Yes. Leviticus 22:20-2
says that all animals used in offerings
had to be blemish free without defect.
This would include this. This would
include the scapegoat. Is Satan blemish
free? And I'll preface by saying before
you answer because you said this
multiple times.
I'm not claiming Christians are not
claiming that the scapegoat was a
sacrifice. Sacrifice and offerings are
different. So it was a two goats for a
singular sin offering. One of them was
slain which paid the penalty for sin.
The other one had a different function.
But the two together served as a
singular sin offering. So because
Leviticus says that all offerings, not
just sacrifices, but offerings have to
be blemish free, does Satan fit the bill
for that?
Well, um, God could have decided to
forgive man's sin without even doing
sacrifice. That's my opinion. But if he
decided to um say that we have to
present animals to be to make atonement
for our sins
and the animal has to be blamefree, it
is an opinion to God alone. So to say
that whether Satan is blames free or not
blamefree, he want to present a concept
for us to know that this is how I'm
going to do it and this is how I'm going
to uh forgive people sin and eradication
and destroy sin. Reunites with the one
as he reunites with the devil he's
reuniting
the people that he has forgiven their
sins with him. So grouping Satan and sin
together reserved for the day of
destruction. So whether the enma is
blamish or whatever, it is an opinion
known to god. It's not known is not
something that we should put in mind to
it that oh the animal is blameless. So
it should be it should be the son of
Jesus uh the son of god.
Well you didn't answer the question. God
says in the the Levitical law system
that all sacrifices and offerings have
to be blemish free. So if you're saying
that the antitype is different than the
type, well in the type it had to be
blemish free. It had to be a blemishree
goat. But in the antitype, well that
doesn't really have to port over. Um
well, Satan doesn't fit the bill of
that. Which this is the same parallel
that we see in Leviticus 14. By the way,
folks, you can check this out. Leviticus
14 1-7. Similar process. And this isn't
the only one. There's actually another
one as well for molds. Um later in the
same chapter, house molds 48:es 48-53.
Leviticus 14 has the same thing. You
have a singular sin offering, two doves,
and it's for the cleansing of diseases.
And one is slain, and then the live one
is dipped in the blood of the slain one,
and then it is set free, representing
the disease being taken away from the
people. That's exactly what the
scapegoat did. So that leads me to my
next question. Do you agree with
Leviticus 16:10
that says, "Attonement was made on the
scapegoat."
Atonement is made on the scapegoat, the
scapegoat. I we see it to be a we see it
to be a a a garage bus or let me say a
bus that carry the sins the sins away.
Right. So this is this is a
a garbage truck. That's the word I'm
trying to use. So it we don't we don't
need to even move forward without
knowing the word what aazel means or the
escape goat means. So if you understand
what the escape goat means, it will help
you narrate help you understand what
those things represent. So it's not up
to us to just put our mind that oh
um
the as I mentioned earlier I'm I was
saying that after all the sins have been
done
their sins have been atoned for the sins
have been placed upon itself the word
mentioned that it was itself so Satan
responsible for the committing bringing
knowledge of forbidden forbidden
knowledge to humanity. He he was a cause
of sin and then the sins have been
placed upon him and then sent away. So
understanding the word asel is first
point to understand what it represents.
So it's not up to us to uh put our mind
into it and then try to manipulate it.
Well, I'm not I'm not manipulating
anything. So the reason I ask is because
your church's own fundamental belief
book. I'm going to read this quote and
ask if you agree with this because your
church agrees that Satan is a part of
the atonement. So folks, this is from
page 369, chapter 24, the investigative
judgment, the heavenly sanctuary. I
typed this up myself. I have the book
right here. You can check this out. It's
going to have a small quote from one of
their scholars and then it's annotated
where the SDA Bible commentary begins.
And this is what it says. If Aazel
represents Satan, how can scripture
connect him with the atonement? And then
in brackets in the book they have it
Leviticus 16:10. As the high priest
after having cleansed the sanctuary
placed the sins of Azazil who was
forever removed from God's people. So
Christ after having cleansed the
heavenly sanctuary will place the
confessed and forgiven sins of his
people on Satan who will then be forever
removed from the saved. This is where
the SCA commentary begins. How fitting
that the closing act of the drama of
God's dealing with sin should be a
returning upon the head of Satan of all
the sin and guilt that issuing from him
originally once brought such tragedy to
the lives of those now freed of sin by
Christ's atoning blood. Thus the cycle
is completed. The drama ended. Only when
Satan, the instigator of all sin, is
finally removed can it truly be said
that sin is forever blotted out of God's
universe. In this accommodated sense, we
may understand that the scapegoat has a
part in the atonement. Leviticus 16:10.
With the righteous saved, the wicked cut
off, and Satan no more, then not till
then will the universe be in a state of
perfect harmony as it was originally
before sin entered.
Do you agree with the statement there
that in an that accommodated sense,
Satan is a part of the atonement?
As I just said earlier, I said as as God
is want to make his people one with
himself by forgiving their sins, he also
make simultaneously make sin
one with the originator. Who is the
originator? Satan. Then so that all will
be destroyed in
where does the where does Leviticus
where does Leviticus 16 say that? What
verse says, "Show us where Leviticus 16
says that the scapegoat represents
responsibility."
One, first of all, the word is Aazel.
The word is Aazel means that a fallen
angel, the prince of uh the prince of
demons or all those things. So,
that's going to backfire as well. We'll
we'll get to that. But I'm trying to be
patient with you, but you're not really
answering the questions. You're kind of
just giving your opinion back. Um, and
you had 15 minutes to present. So now
we're kind of digging into this.
You didn't want to agree with the
fundamental beliefs book, which says
that in an accommodated sense, yet Satan
is Hold on, sir. Hold on. You wanted to
say in an accommodated sense, the book
does that he's a part of the atonement.
You then said we shouldn't really be
peeking behind that and and poking into
those things. So that's not really an
answer. So you haven't answered really
any of the questions so far. You didn't
you didn't answer about being blemish
free, etc. Now, I'm asking you, so I
would I would like an answer on this
one, a direct answer, because you should
be able to show us this. We're supposed
to be examining this from scripture.
Show us where Leviticus 16 says anything
about the scapegoat representing
responsibility.
I should show you where
first of all one point
the word is. Never use scape goat the
Bible.
Wait for me to talk. The second point is
as represent the devil.
Then after the sins of the people have
been atoned for iron is going to put all
the sins upon the good on itself.
There's good commission is symbolic.
That's the point. The thing is that it
is the the aazel they represent is is
symbolic about Satan and what God
planned of how he's going to deal with
the whole sin. The atonement what I'm
just saying is reconciliation
as God is reconciling the people of is
the people of Israel he's reconciling
sin with it originator to be destroyed
as he's also simultaneously make the
people of Israel one with himself.
Right. So the text says nothing about
the scapegoat bearing responsibility.
Notice what you the verse that you're
quoting where you're saying itself.
Itself.
Yes.
That doesn't say anything about
responsibility. That's the scapegoat
bearing that. Hold on, sir. That's the
scapegoat bearing the sins of the
people. So you still haven't showed us
that Satan is blemish free, thus fitting
the the type and the antitype. You
haven't demonstrated for us that the
scapegoat represents responsibility.
You also didn't want to agree with the
fundamental waste book that says in an
accommodating sense Satan is a part of
the atonement. With that, I was going to
ask you if that's the case and you've
mentioned it in your opening. You just
mentioned it again right now. You're
saying that Satan and Jesus reconcile
you to God. Do you believe that Satan is
part of reconciliation?
I didn't say Satan reconcile me to God.
That's what I'm asking. I'm asking I I
said
whilst the people of Israel are being
forgiven, he simultaneously
reuniting sin with it originator. The
point is it's a day of atonement making
one with once the people of Israel are
make one with their creator God is also
removing sin simultaneously making sure
that sin with it originator are being
destroyed in the last day. That's what I
said.
Yeah. Well, no, I was asking you a
question because the sin offering is
part of what the day of what?
The sin offering is part of the day of
atonement.
Okay. Okay. And what is atonement?
You've said in your in your opening, I
wrote it down. You put up experation and
reconciliation. My man, you guys are
saying
Satan and Jesus reconcile you to God
because Satan expedates your sins.
That's what the scapegoat's function
was. It was not responsibility. It was
expeation. The reason that two goats
were needed was because a single goat
could not suffice for what was necessary
for atonement. You had to have the
penalty for sin which is death. But a
second goat was necessary to remove the
sins. That's what expeation is. So
without both you don't have
reconciliation. You don't have an a
completed atonement. Death is not
enough. Just like if Christ would have
only died, Paul tells us in 1
Corinthians 15, and not resurrected, you
don't have reconciliation. You have to
have both. You have to have the perfect
work of Christ. You have to have the
death, burial, and resurrection. You
have to have all of it. It's the same
thing here. You have to have it all.
That's why it was two goats for a
singular sin offering. So if you're
saying it is Satan, what you're saying
is that Satan expedates your sins away,
which is necessary to be reconciled to
God. So Jesus and Satan accomplish that.
My point is, as I said it continuously,
I still say it again. If you don't
listen
sin as God is making one with the people
of God, he is also making one the sin
with the sin causer. The one who who
brought sin to the world. So
sin didn't come in the world by Satan.
Sin came sin came into the world by
Adam.
Romans 5.
It doesn't say
no. Adam no one caused Adam to sin. Adam
did. Adam chose to sin. This is kind of
the problem is Adventists think that
Satan makes makes them sin.
So, so you disagree with the Bible who
which who says that Satan brought sin to
the world.
Where what's the verse?
All right.
Because we'll go to Romans 5, which
explicitly says that Adam brought sin
into the world.
Okay.
Therefore, just as sin came into the
world through one man and death through
sin and so death spread to all men
because all sinned. Paul is talking
about federal headship here. How
original sin spread to all of humanity
through one man. Sin entered the world
by Adam, not Satan.
And how did s how did Adam got a sin?
By by sinning.
My man, this this is part of the problem
with SDA theology is there's so much
extra great controversy stuff right in
about Satan that the Bible just doesn't
say. The Bible has very little to say
about Satan.
It doesn't say that Satan the sin
entered the world by Satan. I know that
you may think it's like, "Oh, well
that's logical because Satan had to have
fallen from heaven." You were just
telling us earlier we shouldn't be
trying to read into things and we
shouldn't be using logic and we
shouldn't be, you know, I know it says
it has to be blemish for you, but that's
up to God. We shouldn't worry about
that. Well, now you're trying to read
into scripture something that's not
there. Show us where the Bible says that
Satan is how sin entered the world.
Hold on.
While you're trying to bring that up, I
will have Well, are you going to be
quick? I don't want us to lose track of
this, but I also don't want to sit here
with a bunch of dead air because I got a
number of other questions I would like
to ask. But I want to get to your other
point about uh the name that seemed to
be a big emphasis for you that Azazil is
a demon. And so um do you have your
verse about Satan being
how sin entered the world,
my man? I'll be honest with you. It's
it's not there. So,
is there
just just no
it's not there, my man. Um,
just just accept that the Bible's not
going to contradict what Paul says in
Romans 5:12, that sin entered the world
by by Adam. Um, it's just that that's a
fact. This is like a huge this is a huge
reason, too, because this is the
problem. If you think that Satan is
ultimately responsible for sin, it
creates all sorts of issues because God
works through federal headship. God sees
uh the sin of nations for example. He
sees the sins of people groups
sometimes. Um and then also he sees
people as rep. So like he says in there
if you keep reading in Romans 5:12-14
he says we read it by sin uh the world
uh sin entered the world through man
through one man and death to all men
because all sinned. Well all of mankind
wasn't born at one singular time. So how
could all people have sinned? Because
God federally looked at Adam as the
federal head. This is why the second
Adam coming, Jesus, it's such a big deal
because he did what the first Adam
failed to do such that he can be our new
federal head and in him we can be seen
as righteous. But you can't have that
when you don't have a completed
atonement and you have uh Satan being a
co-artner with Christ in this. But let's
get back to your question here about or
your your statement about the name.
you're really hung up on the term Azil.
Now, my man, are you aware that there
are four primary um understandings of
the term Aazil and where they're all
coming from?
Yeah, I've I've read through. But
so you know what all you know what all
four because the position you're taking
on this with the name is I'm not saying
that this automatically makes it wrong
but it is the minority amongst the
minority positions. It is the bottom
because you have to quote apocryphal
texts which is what you did because
nothing in scripture tells you that Azil
is a demon. The translation also too
that you're referring to when you're
saying that some translations use it and
some don't that has to do with the
Maseretic text the Hebrew manuscripts.
There are some where there's a
punctuation mark on the name and that
affects whether it is well we're not
going to get into all that. That's why
it's interpreted certain ways. So this
idea that it's just oh it's just cut and
dry. It's just a figure. You said Oazil
is the name of is being used as a name
for Satan. So if that's the case, let me
read six through 10. And instead of
Aazil, I'm going to say Satan. Okay.
Yes.
Because you're saying it's Satan.
He says, "Aaron shall offer the bull as
a sin offering for himself and shall
make atonement for himself and for his
house. Then he shall take the two goats
and set them before the Lord at the
entrance of the tent meeting.
And Aaron shall cast lots over the two
goats, one lot for the Lord and one lot
for Satan."
And Aaron shall present the goat on
which the lot fell for the Lord, and use
it as a sin offering. But the goat on
which the lot fell for Satan shall be
presented alive before the Lord to make
atonement over it that it may be sent
away into the wilderness to Satan. So
question for you that last verse verse
10. If Satan is the scapegoat itself,
how can Satan be sent to himself in the
wilderness if he is the scapegoat?
God is the one who has the supreme power
over all things in the world showing
that he so the the good present before
the Lord which is for us as shows God's
supremacy over how he's going to deal
with sin and then destroy it completely.
So the Bible consistently tell us God's
supremacy over everything his power over
Satan and then everything. So he's
overseeing it and then making sure that
everything is being destroyed.
Um, one of the scripture I wanted to
bring about um, which I really struggled
to bring about hold up. We we'll get to
that in a moment. Let's finish this one.
Let's finish this one out first.
Satan shall be presented alive before
the Lord to make atonement over it. So
you should say him. Aazil shall be
presented alive before the Lord to make
atonement over him that it may that he
may be sent away into the wilderness to
Satan. So Satan is the scapegoat who's
sent away in the wilderness to Satan.
Doesn't work. That's why the translation
is scapegoat because when you see the
scapegoat as a function, the goat of
escape, experation, the one that takes
the sins away, you know, like John the
Baptist said about Jesus, John 1:29,
behold the lamb of God that takes away
the sins of the world.
Jesus takes the sins away, not Satan. So
when you plug in scapegoat here, it
works because it's talking about a
function. It's not talking about an
individual.
It's talking about an individual. So
one one thing about about this is um it
says over it. So the Bible doesn't
consider Satan to be anything. So he use
the word for it. So this is this is a
kind of a u it's not like they want to
exalt Satan then give him a proper name.
He used the word for it because the the
goat represent it represent is it
represents Satan showing how the plan of
atonement is going to be
right. Satan's going to bear the sins
after Jesus is finished and he'll
expedate and take the sins away and then
you'll be reconciled to God because your
sins will be separating you from God no
more. That's uh blasphemous, my friend.
you and other one listen to my statement
God the reason why Jesus died is to make
people one with him not Satan with him
so the people are making God is making
uh Jesus is making uh people one with
God his father and at the same time when
the sin are being he's he's done
atonement atoning for us he's going to
remove the sin and put it on Satan.
That's where Satan is going to be
destroyed with sin
and whoever follows him and didn't
accept the atonement he has done for
humanity.
Um
the only problem with that man is that's
not what the text says. The function of
the scapegoat in the text is the removal
of sin from the people. If Satan does
that because he's the scapegoat, that
means Satan until he removes your sins
away from you, you're not reconciled to
God because as you mentioned,
okay, so you're muted. That's not how
this is going to work. I run the show.
You had 15 minutes and then we were
going to discuss
if Satan is the scapegoat.
He functions as expeation because that's
what the scapegoat in the text does.
That's what Azazil is the goat of escape
for expeation. In your own definitions
that you brought up, I wrote it down.
You had atonement and underneath it was
expeation and reconciliation.
The scapegoat functioned as expeation.
Until that is done, you're not
reconciled. You can't just say, "Well,
Jesus died, so I'm reconciled because he
died." No,
that wasn't the purpose of having two
goats. Furthermore, you need to explain
to us, sir, when lots were cast over
Jesus and Satan to see who would be who.
When did this action of lots being cast
over Jesus and Satan happen?
Go ahead. When did the lots get cast
over Jesus and Satan to see who would be
who?
I don't get your question.
The text says verse 8, Aaron shall cast
lots over the two goats, one lot for the
Lord and one lot for Aazil. You're
saying that that's Satan. The one lot
for the Lord, one lot for Satan. When
were lots cast over Jesus and Satan to
see who would be who.
Laws were not were never cast for Jesus
or Satan. But
right there, buddy, it's right there.
I'm saying
that's part of the ritual.
Yeah.
This is the type. If this is the type,
then
if this is the type, does that port over
to the antitype? You can just say that
doesn't actually port over to the
antitype.
the the the there were a lot of things
that were Jesus is not just a good let
me say the the the sacrifice that were
done to atone for the people's sins is
not only a good ram was there Bu was
there and stuff so this this tells us
that the the the um the the complete
difference between the two things so in
one aspect bull bull ram and Other
things were added to make atonement for
the people. And here it's only one kind
of animal. One is for one has been done
with um cing of laws and one the law
chooses and then is part of the
atonement to atone for the sin of the
people and the other one is never
is is sent away and atonement is made
upon it removing the garbage truck to
remove the sins from the people away
from us. So the same the same way
um
in the last day when when uh we are
being atoned for we are everything has
been done completely and Jesus is coming
and then destroy the whole one uh after
he has taken his people away he's going
to destroy everything because even uh uh
somewhere in Matthew it says uh when he
come he will separate the sheep his his
people from the others like a a shepherd
separates ships from good. So when he
separate his what whatever is his he he
cast the rest out. So is the one who
chooses to do so.
Okay. So I think we've hit that point um
that third or fourth point there. Um
good enough. We'll let the audience um
see for themselves. You mentioned the
other animals here that there's a bull
for a burnt offering etc. Question is
Jesus the antitypical fulfillment of all
of the laws sacrifices and offerings
meaning the sin offering the guilt
offering the fragrant offering etc.
is Jesus the bull there as well the
burnt offering.
Yeah sacrifice. So everything that is
done in the temple of the Lord is for is
a prototype for Jesus. Whatever is not
in the temple sent away which blood was
never used for atonement or anything is
never for the Lord. Right? The function
of the scapegoat again my man is
expeation. That was the purpose. It was
part of a singular sin offering. You're
leaving that part out. Both goats
functioned as a singular sin offering.
You're breaking the sin offering up
between two individuals. So I'm asking
you, you you said this all sacrifices,
stuff that took place, is it only
sacrifices? Jesus is only the
antityypical fulfillment of sacrifices
but not offerings.
Everything done in the temple of God
that were used for the temple of God.
Whereas sprinkling of blood is for is
for God
only sprinkling.
Jesus did that. He paid he paid for our
sins and then he did everything that he
could to reconcile us with God. And then
when he's when he's done he take his
people away he's going to destroy sin.
Same thing as we see sent to the
wilderness where everything is being
destroyed.
So only he's only he only fulfills the
things that typify blood.
Yes. Because if there is no remission of
if there's no sharing of blood, there's
no remission of sin. So Jesus cannot be
the scapegoat because that that blood
was never shed.
Well, you just said earlier that God you
just said earlier God didn't even need
to do sacrifices for forgiveness. That
was your own personal opinion. That's
what you opened with. But now you're
saying that the shedding of blood is
necessary for remission of sins. So you
don't think then that Jesus
listen listen the statement was is God
God could have God can choose to forgive
people's sins without doing sacrifice is
his own opinion but if he decide to do
so he want to use animals without
blamings he choose to do whatever he
likes that's what is reserved for God
so you don't so you don't think that
Satan was the free will offerings
or the first fruits
no blood was was utilized in those
offerings.
Whatever blood is required sin.
Well, well, the scapegoat does involve
blood, my man. Um, which is really what
I'm I'm trying to get at. You just said
that anything that involves blood in
involves Jesus. Well, the scapegoat
bears the the sins in the blood and then
is is sent out. So, it does involve
blood for the singular sin offering.
Are you asking a question or you are
making a contribution?
No, I'm I'm I'm telling you. You you
just admitted earlier. I don't think you
see it. You just admitted earlier that
anything that involves blood
Jesus is the fulfillment of the
scapegoat. Blood was not shed, but blood
was involved. It carried the sins away
and it was presented before the Lord in
the ceremony as a part of the offering
and then bore the blood. So blood, the
blood of the of the offering was
involved. It just wasn't the goat's own
blood. Because again, a dead goat could
not expedate because it was an animal.
Jesus is a much better sacrifice. He can
be all of the laws and he can be all the
laws, sacrifices, and offerings in one.
The guilt offering, the fragrant
offering, the peace offering, the sin
offering, the guilt offering, etc. He's
all of it. Not just if there's blood
involved. He's the first fruits. He's
all of it. So why are you attributing
one aspect of Jesus's completed work? He
came to fulfill all righteousness. That
would include filling fulfilling all of
the law and the prophets. That would
include all of the law sacrifices,
offerings, what the prophets foretold,
etc. It's all about Jesus. But you're
then taking one little sliver in aspect,
the removal of sin from the people, and
ascribing that to Satan when that's
Jesus's work.
Satan didn't remove the sin. It's God
who placed the sin on Satan.
Yeah. Which is what Jesus did in bearing
our sins in his body on the cross. 1
Peter 2:23. God placed our sins onto
Jesus.
Behold the lamb of God who takes away
the sin of the world. He bore them in
his body on the cross. And Colossians 1
says that by the blood of his cross he
made peace.
Jesus Jesus is here. Here here is the
main point. Um
Jesus is what the whole thing about um
it says that uh let me say Romans
chapter
chapter um says verse 23 uh says verse
23. It says, um,
hello.
Yeah, I'm here. I'm just letting you
finish.
Yeah. Okay. In in Romans Ro uh Romans
chapter 6 verse 23, it says uh where is
my scripture?
If you want to share your screen, you'll
have to follow that same process I
showed you earlier.
Yeah.
What verse is it? Romans what?
163.
Okay.
Okay. It says the main point is it says
the wages of sin is death but the free
gift of God is eternal life in Christ
Jesus our Lord. So the the whole point
is um why Jesus is forgiving our sins is
because he paid for the price. He paid
for the price. He's not bearing sin
itself. So that's the main point. Why
should I
why why do I need to believe in Jesus
Christ? Because I s
I'm I'm in depth.
623. I didn't say 24.
No, I I know I'm I'm bringing this up
because we're responding to your claim
that Jesus did not bear sin when the
Bible says that Jesus himself bore our
sins in his body on the tree. And notice
the tail end part
that we might die to sin and live to
righteousness. By his wounds, you have
been healed.
Jesus bearing our sins in his body is
what removed them from us. He's bearing
he's he's he's bearing the the word that
that B there uh because he used his
blood to pay for our sins. That's the
cause he's doing to pay for our sins.
It's not just uh uh he's boring sin
itself. He's bearing the cause of it,
not sin itself. That's the point.
He bore our sins
in his body. He made him who knew no sin
to be sin so that we could be the
righteousness of God. Man, this this is
replete in the scriptures. Furthermore,
again, Jesus, behold the lamb of God who
takes away the sin of the world. Jesus
takes the sin away. Now for Romans 16,
Yep. Go ahead.
He's take he's borrowing the sins of the
world because he he is paying the cost.
Borrowing the cost. That's the point. So
yeah, that's that's death. This says he
himself bore our sins,
not just the penalty for sins.
It's both. It's not an either or. It's a
both and.
If if I bear the cost of something, I
bear it on my pocket or anything. So he
bore the sin because he using his body
or his blood which is in his body, he
has to share it to pay for the cause of
sin. That is the point. So understanding
Romans 6:23 will help her understand all
these things.
Did you say I'm sorry I'm having a
heart. Are you saying Romans 16 or 6?
Romans 6:23. The wages of sin is death.
Yes.
Yeah. That's it's not a mutually
exclusive thing, my my man. It's a it's
a bothand.
Jesus pays the penalty for sin, which is
death, while also removing the sins
away. He's all of this stuff. I don't
see how you can't get it and see it.
He's all of it. Why are you making it?
Well, he's only this. He can only be
this over here. But then, well, he's
actually all the other sacrifices and
offerings, too. But not the scapegoat. I
don't know why you you guys are so
gung-ho on attributing to Satan some of
Jesus's accomplished work, taking away
from the greatness and the glory of the
Lord Jesus and ascribing it to of all
people the devil.
Um I see it to be blasphemous when you
you you you know very well that as
represent Satan and then you attribute
it to Jesus Christ is so blasphemous. I
could never say I can never say in my
spirit that Jesus Jesus is Satan which
you know that Satan Satan is the same as
as an asism. No, no, I don't. No, I told
you earlier I I don't agree with that
position. Um because that's the minority
of the minority position because you
have to appeal to Jewish apocryphal
texts, you know. Um since you're on that
right now, do you know what the Jewish
Mishna is?
I don't know that. And I I don't know.
don't know that
the Mishna is the uh Jewish rabbis,
their exegetical um
it's their exegetical work of the text.
It's the Jewish rabbis official exesus
of the Hebrew text. So I want to look at
the Mishna now and I want you to see
what they say about the scapegoat. Okay?
Since you were appealing to extra
biblical sources like the book of Enoch
and these apocryphal sort of texts,
let's look at how the Jewish rabbis
understand
the two Yam Kapor goats. The mitzvah of
the two Yamapouring goats. This is him
commenting on uh I can't pronounce the
the last name, but this is the the
commenting on the Hebrew text.
Read the read the English.
I am I I I don't read I don't speak
Hebrew. Um, the mitzvah of the two yon
kaparin goats, the goat sacrificed to
God and the goat sent to Ozazil that are
brought as a pair is as follows. That
they both be identical in appearance,
color and in height and in monetary
value and their acquisition must be as
one. They must be purchased together.
And even if they're not identical,
nevertheless, they are valid. And
similarly, if he acquired one today and
one tomorrow, they're valid.
They understood again blemish free. They
had to be identical. So, do you agree
with this exposition? Do you think that
they understand a little something about
the day of atonement ritual? And in
conjunction with Leviticus 22, which
says that all sacrifice, well, in that
specific passage, all offerings have to
be blemish free. Does Satan fit the bill
for that? Did they understand what you
are saying?
I I have watched other Jewish rabbi who
also stand with my position. So what
they wrote there it doesn't is still is
still the the controversy we are having
here. So it doesn't make a point to me.
I said this thing from secular sources
and I had my information that the asel
is Satan it's not from SDA or it's not
from any person it's from secular
sources. And once Satan is Azor, Satan
is the same as Azarel. You can't give
that one to
can't say that one is for Jesus Christ
or anything like that. I've watched
several things and I've read even to.com
which is for Jewish site about all this
stuff.
Yeah, man. Jewish commentators.
Yeah, Jewish commentators
know all this uh uh this these two
positions. Sorry for interrupting.
It's not two positions. There's four
positions on this. I asked you about
that earlier and you said you you knew
that um your position that you're saying
amongst Jewish commentators is not the
normative position. I can guarantee you
that um they are they're saying the same
thing that I'm telling you because
that's where I'm getting this
information from. I'm not just asserting
this. The idea that it is a formal name
and it's actually the wilderness demon
um is coming from Jewish folklore
sources as well as apocryphal texts. It
is not predominantly coming from
scripture. So the idea that oh it's just
clear in scripture that you're calling
Satan Jesus. Well, no it's not. Which is
why the majority of translations
translate it as the scapegoat's function
which is scapegoat. So they translate it
as scapegoat. But now I have another
question for you. We're at about an hour
here. This should be uh the the the
final one here and then we'll we'll wrap
things up.
Is Jesus still dealing with sin such
that it will need to be transferred to
Satan? Because think about it, this idea
is predicated upon the investigative
judgment in the sanctuary teaching. If
sin is not still being dealt with and
sin has already been dealt with, then
that wouldn't mean that there's going to
be a point in the future where sin will
be transferred to Satan. So is Jesus
still dealing with sin such that it will
need to be transferred to Satan?
Um the point is we are we are not yet in
heaven. That's first point. The second
point is we are still dealing with sin
in our in ourself and
um Jesus is still the one who is
mediating even if he mediate for you.
about how about the child or somebody
who who is yet to even hear of Christ to
come and then to come and then listen to
the gospel. What happened to his sins?
So Jesus is still mediating and then
officiating over people who who are
willing to confess their sins and then
give them up. He he he will atone for
them and make them one with God and then
everything will be covered. um he then
they will discard and then destroy the
devil with all his angels and sin and
then we are done with everything. So,
Seventh Day Adventism teaches that you
have to confess every one of your sins
after making a profession of faith. And
that sin is then transferred to the
heavenly sanctuary in your record
through an angel that's been assigned
over you to document this down. And that
sin is transferred to the heavenly
sanctuary. And when you confess it,
Jesus blotss it out using his blood.
Now, some people will say that's
figurative and and yada yada. The the
point regardless of that is the same.
The teaching is that Jesus is still
dealing with sin. Correct? That's what
you're saying.
I'm not denying confession, etc., but
you're say that's that's what you're
saying. Okay. How does that jive with
what we are told really through the
whole book of Hebrews, but specifically,
how does that jive with what we are told
in Hebrews 9, specifically verse 26, but
I'm going to start up at 23. So, he's
laying down the compare and contrast
between Christ and the Levitical ironic
priesthood. And he is finishing things
up from chapter seven here where he's
then going to transfer into the book end
of chapter uh yeah chapter 10. But
notice what he says. Thus it was
necessary. So he's now talking about the
contrast with Christ. So he talks about
how it was on the earthly. He lays out
the the uh layout of the earthly holy
place etc. And he talks about uh yeah
redemption through his blood. And then
towards the end here he says this. Thus
it was necessary for the copy of the
heavenly things to be purified with
these rights. But the heavenly things
themselves with better sacrifices
plural sacrifices than these. That's
what I was getting at earlier about
Jesus was more than just the uh sin
offering. For Christ has entered not
into holy places made with hands which
are copies of the true things, but into
heaven itself now to appear in the
presence of God on our behalf. Nor was
it to offer himself repeatedly as a high
priest enters the holy places every year
with blood not his own. So unlike the
Old Testament Levitical ironic priests,
Jesus didn't have to do sacrifices over
and over and over and over again. He was
a single sacrifice. I know you guys
aren't saying that there's multiple
sacrifices going on. Just laying that
out there. And then notice what he says.
For then he would have had to suffer
repeatedly since the foundation of the
world. But as it is, he has appeared
once for all at the end of the ages to
put away sin by the sacrifice of
himself.
Sin was put away
in Christ's sacrifice at the cross. He's
not dealing with sin anymore. He's not
up in heaven doing the Levitical ironic
priesthood work, but or analogous work,
but only in heaven, not on earth. His
priesthood is completely different than
the Levites because he is a priest king.
You're told in uh Hebrews 7:1, Malachi
or uh MelkiseDC was a high priest and he
was also a priest king of Salem. So
Christ's priesthood is one of not just
being a high priest, but a king. So
Christ is ruling and reigning right now
as a priest, king, making all of his
enemies a foottool, which is what we're
told twice in the book. He's not dealing
with sin anymore. Sin was already put
away by the sacrifice of himself at the
cross, which is why we can actually have
a cleansed conscience. The author tells
us unlike the bull the the blood of
bulls and goats which were not able to
actually take away sin. Christ is
actually able to take away sin like the
scapegoat such that our consciences can
be cleaned. The work of the Levitical
ironic priesthood was a continuous
reminder to the people that their sin
needed dealt with. That's what the
author tells us. And so if Christ was up
in heaven doing analogous work to the
Levitical ironic priesthood but only in
heaven, your sin's not dealt with. And
this goes back to the the point that I
was saying, Satan ultimately caps off
the atonement. It's not complete until
Satan is involved.
It's blasphemous.
Um you just quote here that um sin was
put away by his sacrifice. He's talking
about the sacrifice he did on the cross
and then he said is finished but not
complete.
And then why
the the point was sin is taken away. I
didn't say I didn't I wasn't arguing
that it not being complete that there's
other points we could go to for that. I
asked the question is Jesus still
dealing with sin in heaven. You said
yes. This says sin was put away at the
cross.
He died on the cross to get to obtain
the blood for the remission of sin. So
he
he he he
got the um we have the blood of Jesus
Christ when he died on the cross. And
then why he's why uh Hebrews is talking
about when he he now enter the holy
place to atone for our sins. If it is
come, if it is finished and put away on
the cross, when he enter into heaven,
why is he entering the holy places
again?
It says
he doesn't need to enter into any place.
If that is a point and the whole book of
Hebrews would have been irrelevant of
talking about these things,
we no the book of Hebrews absolutely
decimates this whole entire concept. Um,
but we just saw that Jesus entered into
heaven itself. That's what the text said
that that's what the holy place is is
you you guys are hung up on this idea of
a tabernacle building up in heaven and
Jesus is moving around on a throne with
wheels and all this other crazy stuff.
Hold on, sir. Hold on, sir. Hold on,
sir.
So, because you guys are hung up on
that, you're you're missing what's being
said. The parallel is that Christ
entered heaven itself. That is the most
holy place. That's where God's presence
is manifest in heaven. That is the holy
place. Wherever God is manifest is the
most holy place. So Jesus entered one
time by the sacrifice of himself,
presented himself, was accepted, and sat
down on his throne to rule and reign as
a priest king. He's not dealing with sin
anymore. Furthermore, in your guys's
system, because your sin is not actually
removed from you yet, notice what it
says. This is after and we actually need
to go back to Hebrews chapter nine where
he says while the Levitical priesthood
work was going on. The way for us into
the presence of God was not open. Only
the high priest could go in one time a
year at that as well. But now notice the
contrast. Therefore, brothers, since we
have confidence to enter the holy places
by the blood of Jesus, by the new and
living way that he opened for us through
the curtain, that is through his flesh.
The curtain was the doorway into the
presence of God. Jesus is our doorway
into the presence of God. The curtain
was his flesh. That's what the the
curtain represented. All the temple
imagery represented Christ, the bread,
the light of the world, etc. But then he
says, "And since we have a great high
priest over the house of God, let us
draw near with a true heart in full
assurance of faith, with our hearts
sprinkled clean from an evil conscience
and our bodies washed with pure water."
There's no way that this could be
possible in your guys' system because
your sin is still being dealt with just
like the Levitical ironic priests who
were still dealing with sin. People
couldn't have assurance. People couldn't
actually enter into the presence of God
because their sin still stood against
them. But because Jesus put sin away at
the cross, that single sacrifice,
the barrier is broken. The temple veil
was torn. Contrary to what the Adventist
Church teaches about the temple veil
being torn and the apart that's showing
the change from the earthly to the
heavenly sanctuary. No, it was the
barrier between God and man broken down
which represented Christ's flesh. And
it's by Christ's broken body on the
cross that we can enter into the
presence of God with full assurance
because my sin's not standing against me
anymore. It was already put away. Jesus
is not up in heaven dealing with that
anymore. Because this is the case. There
is no scapegoat in the future for sins
to be transferred to.
your your turn.
[Applause]
Um,
I mean, I don't know why that's really
that funny. Um, it's actually really
sad, man, that you guys can't see this.
This is really serious doctrine.
You you need uh all these scriptures to
talk about uh your full assurance. that
I already I already have my full
assurance in um John 3:16 which says
that um
uh God has sent his son to the world and
whoever believe in him shall not perish
and have eternal life and once I believe
I don't even need to know all this back
back door processes that is going on I
have the full assurance that my sins are
already forgiven this is this is um
uh complimentary information that if you
wish to know, but I don't need Hebrews 2
just to know that I still have full
assurance when I'm already assured in
John 3:16. I don't need all those
things. I have the full assurance. Um,
you you you are like um uh it's like
time when an Israelite confess his sins
and then on and then all these animals
have been sacrificed and sent into to do
all his sin. He he doesn't know that his
sins have been forgiven.
already once he accept and then he
accept the hcept and put his faith in uh
transfer his sins onto all these
animals. He doesn't need to know all the
background that is going on. Meanwhile,
we know that blood are being sprinkled
on the mercy seat and all the sins to
make sure that our our sins are being
forgiven. But a typical Israel doesn't
need to know all this. He has the full
assurance right at where he confess his
sins and then all this uh all the
animals blood has been killed and
sprinkle on the mercy seat. These are
after informations and he doesn't need
to know that one one he just
he transferred his sins already he knew
he's going to be forgiven and that is
through faith he already knew that he
doesn't need any veil to be broken or
anything but this is an after
information that if you care to know if
you care to know what is going behind
doors that will help you uh know how
your sins are being forgiven you will
care to know but if you don't need to
know my sins are already forgiven and
how God is going to deal with them.
You can't you can't possibly know that.
For all you know, you could you could
sin tomorrow and that will now if if
it's not confessed, it will be on your
record because Jesus is still having
having to deal with it, right? So, don't
say that your sin's already dealt with,
man. No, no, it's not. That's where the
type breaks down as well, by the way. Um
where you guys are trying to prove too
much from the type antitype from
Leviticus. Um, just like how lots being
cast over Jesus and Satan ends up
proving too much, this is another area
where you would end up proving too much
with with what you're claiming because
you're you're missing the the point of
of what the the type is. This was good.
Thank you for coming on. We've been at
it for about an hour and 15 minutes.
Wanted to go out about an hour of
discussion and you had 15 minutes there
to open or so. So, thank you my friend.
Um, I respect you for coming on here.
Seriously, thank you for being um bold
enough to, you know, state openly what
you believe, why you believe it. Um
letting other people see. I think it's
good for Christians to um hear from
Adventists themselves from their own
mouth the things that um you guys are
are teaching and believing. So, thank
you for doing that. Um I don't know if
you have like a YouTube channel or
anything that you want to tell people
about. Um, but I'll give you some final
words here for you to sign off and then
uh I'm going to do a couple other things
before wrapping us up here. So, the
floor is yours for any final words.
Um,
I have final words though, but I don't
know why you didn't allow me to ask
questions.
Yeah, you can ask some uh some
questions. I I we talked about in the
thread that you were going to present
and then we were going to ask questions
about the the Adventist position because
I don't think it's it's really
irrelevant what I believe. I'm happy to
answer your questions like I said, but
real quick, um it's really irrelevant
what I believe because if you nullify
what I say, it doesn't automatically
vindicate the default position is not
that Satan is the scapegoat. And then
now it's on everyone else. No, no, the
burden approves on the person making the
positive assertion. And so tonight it
was that Satan is the scapegoat. But ask
uh ask your your questions or a couple
here. We we'll go for a little bit here,
but I got a couple other things I want
to knock out.
Um
what are you doing? Getting a feed from
your your boys.
All right, don't worry. Um let me just
go around.
You guys need to get your you guys need
to get your logistics and your
communications stronger.
Yeah, caught you. Yeah. Um,
yeah, you guys are funny.
I I I see it too like let's let's don't
worry. Let me do my conclusion.
Jonathan, this isn't my this isn't my
first rodeo. I' I've been doing this for
a long time. So, I've watched you get to
your question. Yeah. Get to your
questions. Get to your question.
Um, let me just do my conclusion myself.
Okay. my man. My man, you're you're
going to sign off for the night. Thank
you for being here. I appreciate you.
Um, but if you were going to ask
questions, you guys should have got your
agenda together and had that prepared
before coming on here instead of trying
to do like the live feed where they're
going to like shoot you in the answers
uh and questions and that sort of stuff.
You guys should have been a little
better prepared. So, do your do your
outro and then uh if you want to come
back sometime and maybe talk about
another topic um you you you can come
back. you've been a very nice cordial
gentleman and so let's give your outro
and and close things out on your end.
Okay. Thank you.
Um my conclusion remarks, it is clear it
is clear Jesus Christ cannot be the
scapegoat or Aazel because Aazel is a
fallen angel. Searching for the meaning
of the word is fundamental to understand
the Bible and therefore a careful search
for the word aazel would have helped
anyone who can who want to understand
the day of atonement. It represent
it represent God plan and show how he
reunite us with himself and and
completely remove sin from the new earth
to come. The wages of sin is death but
the free gift of God is eternal life
through Christ Jesus. Why is it free? Is
free because God Jesus Christ paid for
our sins and that is a legal process he
has done and he has redeem us. Redeem
redemption is a legal term to of freeing
slaves. We are slave to sin and then
Jesus free us from sin.
Um, but God show his love for us in that
whilst we were yet sinners, Jesus died
for us. Since
since therefore we have now been
justified by his blood, much more shall
we be saved by him from the wrath of
God. Romans chapter 8 verse chapter 5:8
and 9. Christ paid for the price of
price to free us from the cursed that
the law
that the law in the laws in Moses
teaching bring by becoming cursed
instead of him in instead of us.
Scripture says everyone who is hung on a
tree is cursed. Christ paid the price.
So, so that the blessing promised to
Abraham would have would come to all the
people of the world through Jesus
Christ. And we will receive the promise
of the Holy Spirit through faith in
Revelation that is Gal Galatians 3-14.
Revelation chapter 8 verse 9 to 10. And
by and they sang a new song. You are
worthy to take the scroll and to open it
still because you have you were slain
and with your blood you purchase men for
God from every tribe and language and
people and nation. You have made them to
be
a kingdom and a priest to serve our God
and they will reign on the earth.
Acts chapter 8,
my man,
it's not like a full on clo I I just
wanted you to give your your sign off if
people have anywhere that they would
you'd like to point them to. if you have
a YouTube channel or social media page
somewhere. This was not build as a
formal debate. Um that's not what we
talked about in the the thread. It was
for you to present and then for us to
kind of examine that. And so any sort of
closing words that you'd just like to to
say before we we close out things on on
your end. If you'd like to have a formal
debate, go to answering adventism.com
and fill out the form and request
something like that. we're gonna
something like that would require a lot
more preparation than than something
like this and we would want to be on a
neutral platform more than likely to
have a a moderator um that sort of
thing. So, um just any final thoughts
that you have if you want to point
anyone anywhere or anything like that.
Um thank you for being
yo thank you so much. Um I really
appreciate I have a channel called
Common Sense
um where I present my argument after
listening to people
um about their opinion about whatever
they believe in and I also present my
opinion. I'm and I'm grateful for
whatever you have uh you have given the
opportunity for us to have a discussion
face to face. Um Facebook I also have uh
the same name common sense where I
present uh from day to day assesses and
present my opinion. Thank you so much
and I really appreciate it.
Yeah, if you uh met you have my contact
information if you send me the links to
those things. I'll put them in the
description box down below. So for
people that want to check your stuff out
um or hear any of the you know further
laying out of arguments and stuff, they
can check your channel out. Thanks for
being here.
Yeah, thank you, too.
Yeah.
All right, folks. Well, hopefully that
was beneficial for you to see. Um you
guys can start sending through some
questions if you'd like. Um specifically
about um or preferably about tonight's
topic. Um
that was good. That was good. We do this
because I want Christians to see from
their own mouths what's being said. It's
not answering Adventism, misrepresenting
them.
For all the people too who say you can
never have a discussion with an
Adventist and be cordial. Yep. That
gentleman was very cordial. He didn't
come in kicking the door down. He
reached out and said, "I made a
presentation. I want to challenge and
present the best case that I can for
Satan being the scapegoat." So, we set
it up and he came onto the channel. So,
if you're an Adventist and you want to
do the same thing this gentleman did, go
to answering adventism.com, fill out the
form that is there and um make a a
request, you know, in your message and
we can talk about that. Let's look at
some of the comments here. I know that
there was um somebody saying, yeah, like
this, it should always be the plans have
both uh cross-examined. This was not a
formal debate, folks. This was not built
as a debate. This was built as he is
coming here. And I said this in the
opening. It was in the title. It's in
the description. He will have 15 minutes
to present the best case that he can for
Satan being the scapegoat. I didn't even
I wasn't even taking a a affirmative
position tonight. I had a defensive
position. Um but I didn't have the
affirmative tonight. He had the
affirmative and he was coming to present
his best case from scripture that Satan
is the scapegoat. And then we were going
to discuss afterward and that's what we
did.
Let's see.
Is there anything else in chat? anyone
sending questions through yet? Until
people start sending questions, if they
do have some questions, put a Q if you
can, folks, at the beginning of your
question just to differentiate it from
the rest of the uh the the rest of the
comments. I want to read something while
we're waiting on that.
It's from a book here called Who Shall
Ascend the Mountain of the Lord? by El
Michael Morales.
Professor Morales is the professor of
biblical studies at Greenville
Presbyterian Theological Seminary in
South Carolina.
And he does a phenomenal job. It's a
little bit of a scholastic rigid here.
So, if you get this book, you may have
to read a little slowly, but he does an
excellent job laying out for us what we
see through the whole book of Leviticus.
Not just the day of atonement, not just
chapter 16, but the entirety of what is
happening here. And I want to read
a couple paragraphs here about what he
says regarding the expulsion of the live
goat, the goat of escape. And notice
what he says.
Part of the high priest's duties on the
day of atonement included taking two
young goats and presenting them before
Yahweh at the tent of meetings doorway.
We saw that in the text. to cast lots
for them, one designated for Yahweh and
the other for Aazil. The high priest
would sacrifice the goat whose lot fell
for Yahweh, using its blood to purify
God's house. Upon the head of the second
goat, he would lean both hands,
confessing over it all the guilt and
rebellion of Israel. And then an
appointed man would lead the goat,
symbolically loaded with Israel's sins,
out into the wilderness. Here we are
concerned with the second goat, utilized
for what many may be or utilized for
what may be called an elimination,
right?
The term Azil is problematic and has
defied scholarly consensus with regard
to its meaning. There are four main
suggestions as to its significance. This
is what I was mentioning tonight
with some variety within each. One,
Aazelle either may refer to a demon or
to a god of wrath, perhaps even
expressing Yahweh's own displeasure via
an alter ego. Two, Aazil may refer to a
place, a rocky precipice, or the
uninhabited wilderness. Three, aazil may
simply mean utter destruction. And four,
aazil may signify the goat that is sent
away. Rather than weighing in on the
merits and weakness of each proposal, I
will focus on discerning the
significance of the right itself within
the theological drama of the cultist.
Now, that word cultist there, it just
means a religious ceremony. It's not uh
a it's not talking about like a cult.
Uh I should have marked my place.
Whatever the precise import of the term
Aazil, the basic significance of the
Aazil right is not difficult to discern.
The second goat is used to placard the
removal of Israel's sin and guilt.
Ah
that was the function of the scapegoat
to expedate
In keeping with that understanding, I
will refer to the live goat by its
traditional ascription scapegoat along
with aazil goat as I make the following
two points.
First, the scapegoat's role should be
understood in conjunction with that of
the goat that is sacrificed as an
elimination right. The Azil goat ritual
is often probed in isolation from the
redactional and/or comparative religion
approach within the context of Leviticus
16. However, the right is fully
integrated as part of one complete
ceremony
associated particularly with the young
goat that is sacrificed. For example,
while two rams are also used on the day
of atonement as ascension offerings for
the priestly house and for Israel
respectively, yet these two animals are
not brought together in the same fashion
as the two goats are.
The text is quite careful to portray the
goats as a set. This is in line with the
Mishna as well which says the same thing
and says that they also had to be
identical, blemish free, etc.
The text is quite careful to portray the
goats as a set. The high priest takes
them both from the congregation of
Israel, presents them before presents
them both together before Yahweh at the
door of the tent of meeting, and then
casts lots for them both. The
instructions for the high priest in
Leviticus 16:5, moreover, refer to both
goats together as a single purification
offering. He will take from the
congregation of the sons of Israel male
goats as a purification offering. To be
sure, the expulsion right is not an
offering in the technical sense. This is
where Adventists get hung up because
they say, "Oh, there's no the scapegoat
wasn't sacrificed, so it's not part of
the offering." Nevertheless, in removing
sin, the scapegoat's function fits the
precise significance as purification
and combined with the blood manipulation
of the sacrificed goat completes the
picture of atonement.
Indeed, there is historical precedent
for understanding these goats to be
identical in appearance and chosen
expressly because of this likeness. as
if it were one goat accomplishing two
different aspects of atonement,
purification and expeation, cleansing
from sin's pollution and the removal of
sin's guilt.
This is why 7th Day Adventists this is
such a horrendous teaching.
I understand in the sanctuary system it
makes sense in your mind. The problem is
there are so many holes in that system.
And because the text says nothing about
responsibility, which is foundational to
this whole thing, by the way, look up
all of the mentions of this in Ellen
White's writings. You'll never find a
single proof text for where she says he
represents responsibility. Whether she's
doing it in in context or out of
context, she's constantly quoting
scriptures. But when it comes to this,
no mention because there is nothing in
the text that says anything about
responsibility because that was not the
function of the scapegoat. The function
of the scapegoat was the expeation and
removal of the sins. A dead goat did not
remove the sins away from the people.
They were still present. They were still
there. And the Adventist church has this
entire theory of transference. But the
atonement was not completed until both
goats were utilized along with all of
the other animals. Saying that Satan is
the scapegoat is saying that Satan and
Jesus both accomplish the atonement
together, reconciliation and
purification. He even brought it up in
his own in own definitions there. And so
that's the problem with this teaching.
That is the concern. That is the worry.
Um because there is a lot of reading
Satan into the text when he is not
there. Um and reading all sorts of
things into the text about Satan that
are definitely not there. Like we're
going to see next Thursday. Next
Thursday, folks, you're going to want to
tune in for the live stream. We're going
deep. Adventists, we're talking about
the Sabbath. Um I challenge all of you
show up, listen, and then if you've
heard the presentation afterward, you
want to come on and try and refute it.
not after the presentation because it's
going to be a long presentation. You can
reach out afterward. I challenge every
Seventh Day Adventist out there. Come on
Answering Adventism after next week's
presentation and try and refute what is
said. With that said, let's get into
some of the questions
on here. Roberto asks, "Have you looked
into Sona and what he has written in his
talks on the order of MelkiseDC?" I have
not, but I will jot that down. I'm
always curious. That's one of my
favorite topics to study is the high
priestly work and kingly role of Jesus
Christ. So, no, I haven't, but I will
definitely check that out. Um, my
library has a pretty big selection of
stuff on that and I'm always looking to
add to it. So,
praise I am asks question. Aren't goat
sacrificial ceremonies typologies? Why
do SDAs describe it literally to Jesus?
Um, I'm not exactly sure what your
question is. Um, the scapegoat was not
sacrificed. So, that tends to be a key
thing that they try and pour in into
their argumentation. I debated Adventist
pastor Keith Bowman on this. It's on my
channel for months ago. Um, and he
basically had the same defense that they
did tonight because, well, at the end of
the day, that's what the fundamental
beliefs
in the fundamental belie
mentioned three of them. He didn't
mention the fourth point. Um, so one of
the key arguments is that the scapegoat
was not sacrificed. And so because he
wasn't sacrificed, it couldn't have been
it couldn't have been Christ. So that's
why I asked him tonight, do you believe
that Christ fulfills all of the laws,
sacrifices, and offerings? Because there
were uh offerings that didn't involve
blood. There was first fruits, for
example, which was considered an
offering. Um there was the uh precious
uh the jewelry and precious metals that
were given in in a free will offering.
No blood is involved and yet Jesus is
the free will offering. Um so I hope
that answers your question. Um, I I
think you're maybe thinking that they
say that the scapegoat was sacrificed
and that tends to be the one thing they
want to jump on because if you say the
sin offering, they associate offering
and sacrifices typically as
interchangeable. And that's not always
the case. And the argument is not that
the scapegoat was sacrificed, but that
both goats functioned as a singular
offering to accomplish a singular thing.
And without both, you don't have the
accomplishment of that thing.
Let's see.
This person says, "I challenge you."
Well, you haven't even heard the
presentation yet, so calm down. Like I
said, you guys can go to answering
Adventism.com. You can fill out the form
on there and put in your request, and we
can talk about all of those sorts of
things. But before challenging me,
you're going to need to know what I
present and what I say. Not just assume,
which is another problem a lot of
Adventists have, is assuming that
somebody's going to say something or
believe something. um because it's what
you're used to. I would hold and cool
your horses because um I I highly highly
doubt you understand what I'm going to
be uh presenting and saying.
Tariq Marray asks resources on the
shorter side to learn more about the
sanctuary in Orthodox Christianity.
Well, it depends what you mean by this.
Um because there's a lot of aspects to
the sanctuary. Um, so if you're wanting
to really go deep, I'm again highly
recommending this book, Who Shall Ascend
the Mountain of the Lord? It is a little
bit weighty, but
you can do it. You can do it. Um, you
just need to go through it slowly with
the Bible because that's basically what
he's doing is walking through the book
of Leviticus. It is a seminary type
textbook. Um, so again, it it is a
little weighty, but you can definitely
do it. I highly recommend that because
the sanctuary is is littered all
throughout Leviticus obviously because
well Leviticus is documenting down the
Levitical priesthood work which took
place in the sanctuary. So I would
recommend that. Um but if you have a
more specific aspect of that there's
tons of stuff out there um all the way
back from church fathers up through the
reformers to people present day um in
modern English as well which is um
always nice obviously. So that would be
my recommendation. Marco asks, "Can you
show from scripture who is the fit man
that sends the live goat to the
wilderness?" Yeah, Simon that leads uh
the fit man. Simon is is the the fit man
that leads Christ out of the camp into
um the the wilderness.
Let's see.
Teddla, how do we understand the
scapegoat being led into the land that
is uninhabited? So, one thing, and this
kind of actually goes back to the last
question as well. This is where you have
to be careful with typology, folks. It
depends. If if you try and prove too
much, you run into issues. This is
exactly why I brought up the question,
and it wasn't really rhetorically, but I
already knew the answer to it. I was
asking the question kind of like Jesus
would do sometimes to make a point. Um,
you you can prove too much sometimes
when you try to take typology too far.
The point of the scapegoat being taken
to the wilderness was that it was
removing the sins away from the people.
That's the point. It's not that, oh man,
there has to be a literal wilderness and
he's a literal goat. He's literally the
Lord's goat. Well, no. And even within
the law, there were stipulations for
interchanging goats with lambs and that
sort of thing. So, that's how, for
example, Christ can be the lamb of God
that takes away the sin of the world.
I'm glad this gentleman tonight didn't
make this argument, but I've heard tons
of Adventists make the claim when you
try to say Christ is the scapegoat.
Christ is never represented as a goat.
Well, this is false for a number of
reasons, but one, um, he's not the
Lord's goat. Then that's just a silly
argument, but two, yes, he is. In
Genesis 22, the, uh, type that we see
there between Abraham and Isaac of the
father taking the son who carries the
wood up the mountain to be the
sacrifice. Um, and he says that the Lord
will provide a substitute. This is all
typological obviously of the father
giving up the one and only Jesus to be
sacrificed and that the father would
sacrifice the son. Um and he was the
substitute that was provided. But if you
remember in the story, what is caught in
the thicket bush? A thicket bush is a
thorn bush. It's a ram. That's the
substitute that Abraham says the Lord
provided in this typological setting
right there. That's Jesus the substitute
with the crown of thorns on his head.
That is showing again this
interchangeability of goats, lambs, etc.
which was lawful um amongst the law. So
um I I say all that to say uh I don't
think there has to be a literal
wilderness. I'm not the one that's
drawing out the typology this far. Now
the Adventist church when they try to do
the uh sanctuary and the investigative
judgment, all of a sudden typology
becomes super literal. There's a literal
tabernacle up there. Oh, but there's not
really a curtain with people like Roy
Gain. Um, well, he moved from the holy
to the most holy, but that was more
figurative of a change of work. So, this
is again where typology breaks down when
you try to prove too much. And I think
it's somewhat proving too much, but also
at the same time, um, Christ was led
outside of the camp and the the sins
were placed upon him. He bore them in
his in his body on the cross. Um, and he
was led out by a fit man, Simon, um,
outside of the camp. The text says
that's in uh all the gospels I believe.
Um maybe not John, I can't remember, but
it's in the gospels.
Tariq again also, how did you become so
sophisticated and knowledgeable? Well,
um I stand on the shoulders of giants.
Don't think that I'm coming up with all
these things on my own that I'm some
what have you. Um I I'm not. I'm just a
guy who is a nerd about theology. Um,
you tend to learn and grow in things
that you put time into. That's across
the board. You know, if you're going to
be really good at being a mechanic and
cars, you spend a ton of time on cars.
This is what I spend a ton of my time
doing. I'm super nerded out about
theology. I love theology. I want to
know why I believe what I believe.
That's actually what got me into this
sort of thing. That's what led me out of
Adventism was trying to really get
serious about studying Adventist
theology and realizing uh I couldn't do
it, at least not from scripture. I had
to rely on a number of inferences and um
assumptions that come from outside the
text, mainly from the great controversy
worldview. Um but it's really just
through study. Um but also too, I have
to give really really really
large amounts of credit to my pastors.
I've had sound pastors. Um my my I've
said this before on the channel. I'm
going to continue to say it. I haven't
listed them by name. One of my pastors
is actually going to come on at sometime
so you can see him then. Um, until then,
I'll let them remain unnamed, but they
are incredible men of God, godly,
studious, serious shepherds of Christ's
flock, committed to the text, committed
to living out the call of being fit to
exede from the sacred desk of God's
church and feed Christ sheep with the
word and be a conduit vehicle that um
the the word of God is is feasted upon
and then the sacraments administered.
Um, I I owe a lot to my pastors who are
so focused on scripture. The preaching
is verse by verse by verse through the
Bible. We're singing the Psalms in our
liturgy. It's just littered with
scripture. So through the week, it's
meditating on scripture. It's reading
scripture with your family. It's
catechism with my son. It's when you're
constantly just entrenched in this and
then doing answering Adventism now
full-time, but that hasn't been a a
super long thing. But even prior to
this, studying, reading books, um just
soaking up information, it does not come
overnight. Um and again, I've been doing
that same sort of thing. I mean, I've
been studying scripture daily. Um as
well as just theology proper every day
for over 10 years now. Um so that's
essentially how but again, I'm just
passing off information that I've
learned. That's really where all of this
is coming from. has always been you're
learning from somebody else that is
essentially passing this on to you. So
that's essentially how so thank you for
the uh subtle compliment in there as
well. Truth defenders asks, "Do you see
a distinction of the angel of Gabriel
between the Jehovah's Witnesses and
SDAs? If so, can you explain? Thanks."
Um so I think what you're asking on
this, you got to be a little bit more
pointed, but that's okay. Um, I think
what you're asking is,
am I seeing the connection between Ellen
White's
angel messenger and uh the way that
Gabriel is viewed in the Jehovah's
Witnesses? I'm not sure exactly what you
mean there because um we have to be
careful when we're comparing what
Seventh Day Adventists believe about
I'll use another example with Jehovah's
Witnesses like Michael. They don't
believe the same thing. And oftentimes,
um, to be fair to the Adventists, they
get straw manned or caricatured as
believing the same thing about Michael
that the Jehovah's Witnesses do, and
that is not the case. There's an article
on this, by the way, on my website, uh,
answering a baptism.com. Just go to the
Q&A section and, uh, click under the
Jesus Christ section, and there's one
about is Jesus Michael? Um, and it
explains kind of the uniqueness of the
SDA position. Um, but hopefully that
answers your question.
Uh
question just your thoughts on why the
scapegoat is never referenced in the New
Testament since it seems to be the most
significant of all the Old Testament
types in the rule of sins. the sin
offering is. So, this is kind of what I
was getting at with him as well, is that
while the scapegoat is not listed by
name or uh like the word scapegoat is
not used, uh sin offering is repeatedly
used. And the scapegoat was a part of
the singular sin offering. I'm going to
be doing a series of videos on this
because there's just really not enough
out there in general on this subject,
but also um it it is so vital to
understanding New Testament language to
realize that Paul's not just using pathy
language. He's actually um well, let's
do an example here so I can show you. So
Christ is all of the laws, sacrifices,
and offerings. All of them. They all
pointed to him. The peace offering, free
will offering, the guilt offering, etc.
So, when we're reading the New
Testament, these things are being
mentioned frequently. And if you're not
familiar with this Old Testament law
work, you're going to pass over some of
these things. So, let's use the burnt
offering, which was also the fragrant
offering, um, as an example of what I'm
talking about here. So, if we go to
Genesis 8 20-22, if you have a Bible,
folks, Genesis 8
20-22,
we'll see what happens when Noah got off
of the ark.
And what does it say?
says, ' Then Noah built an altar to the
Lord, which is what God commanded him to
do, and took some of every clean animal
and some of every clean bird and offered
burnt offerings on the altar. So this is
even before the law is is essentially
established with the temple work. We
have the same thing happening, a burnt
offering. And when the Lord smelled the
pleasing aroma, the Lord said in his
heart, "I'll never again curse the
ground because of man, for the intention
of man's heart is evil from his youth.
Neither will I ever again strike down
every living creatures I've done, while
the earth remains, sea time and harvest,
cold and heat, summer and winter, day
and night shall not cease." So Noah
after he is spared through the flood,
which was also typological judgment and
a number of things, he's spared him and
his family, eight people, mind you.
We're going to get into this a little
bit uh in next Thursday, how the number
eight um represents new beginnings,
redemption, that sort of stuff. But they
get off the ark and God commands them,
make an altar and take some of every
clean animal and some of every clean
bird and offer burnt all burnt offerings
on the altar to the Lord. So Noah does
it. And when the Lord smelled the
pleasing aroma,
ah, he said in his heart, so he was
moved by this. And he says, I'll never
again curse the ground because of man.
So he was appeased.
He pours out his wrath. That teaches us
one thing and and Noah is spared in the
ark. And there's a ton of imagery there.
But then he gets off and obeys God. A
burnt offering goes up and it appeases
God's anger and he says, "I'll never do
that again." And then gives the sign of
the rainbow afterward, etc.
So now if we go to Ephesians 5 1 and 2.
Ephesians 5 1 and two.
Therefore be imitators of God as beloved
children and walk in love as Christ
loved us and gave himself up for us a
fragrant offering and sacrifice to God.
Ah,
you parallel that with Isaiah who tells
us, "The Lord was pleased to crush him."
The Lord was pleased to crush the son
who willingly gave himself as a free
will offering. And upon doing so, it
sent up a pleasing aroma to the Lord.
Ah, and his anger toward us, his people,
his children is appeased. That's what
propitiation is. We talked about this a
little bit in the last stream. Look up
the word propitiation, folks. It has to
do with the mercy seat and it has to do
with a deity being appeased.
That's what happened with with Christ.
He was the burnt offering that sent up
the fragrant aroma that caused God's
anger toward his people to be completely
appeased. And that's why Paul says in
Romans 5:1 that we have peace with God,
being justified by faith. We talked
about that again in the in the last
stream. It even mentions there in Romans
5 the wrath of God. So I say all that to
say
it may not mention the scapegoat by name
meaning the word scapegoat may not be
mentioned but the sin offering is
totally depicted in the New Testament.
So just do a lexical study on uh or
search if you will on the sin offering
in the New Testament. Anything that has
to do with Christ giving him himself up
for our sins. And that is essentially
by proxy mentioning the scapegoat
because the removal of sin was a part of
the antityypical sin offering.
Let's see any other questions. Any other
questions?
Gotta put a Q in front of your
questions, folks. It's easy to miss in
the chat. Um,
so it doesn't look like anything else is
here. So, we'll wrap it up tonight with
that. Thanks for being here, folks. I
think again, like I said, that this was
super beneficial. Um, Jonathan, again,
thank you for coming on, sir. If you're
an Adventist and you would like to do
this same sort of thing. Answering
Adventism.com, fill out the contact form
on there. Also, want to just continue
letting people know that answering
adventism.com is live. You can donate
there. You can partner with us. Um, we
have a lot of interesting stuff in the
works. The website is only the
beginning. Um, in the fall we've got
some interesting stuff, some boots on
the ground stuff that's going to start
happening, some new types of content
that are going to be rolling out. Um,
just a bunch of stuff in the works. So,
if any of that stuff is your fancy, you
can check all of that out. Uh, there's
tons of resources there as well. You can
use the super powerful search bar at the
top of the website. Um, simply type in a
question or even just a word like
scapegoat and anything in the video or
question and answer library that has to
do with that will pop up. Everything is
hyperl with all the sources. You can get
lost in that all you want doing the
actual digging into the sources
yourself. Um, again, Adventists, the
call is always the same. It's always the
same. Glad that you guys are here. Those
of you that are in chat, those of you
that will watch this later on, we don't
hate you here. As you can see tonight,
um we can have cordial discussions, um
honest discussions without flying off
the handle. If you don't come in kicking
the door down, um you're not going to be
met with that same sort of energy and
force. Um we care about you. We want you
to come know the truth. The Adventist
Church is proitizing a false gospel. It
is a false church with a false prophet,
a false gospel, and a false Christ.
Neither of which can save you when it
comes to a false go well, I guess
technically to a false church, but um a
false Christ and a false gospel cannot
save you. The Adventist Church has
altered the gospel. You need to turn
from the fake Jesus of Adventism who is
not real. Just like the Jesus of
Mormonism is not real. The Jesus of
Jehovah's Witnesses etc. is not real.
Neither is the Christ of Adventism. The
Bible warns us. Jesus himself says many
false Christs have already gone out into
the world and many more will. Simply
saying the name Jesus is not enough. The
details matter. And when we start to
examine the details of the Adventist
Jesus through the great controversy
theme, um we see that it is a different
Christ than the one of history and
scripture. And so we want you to know
the true Christ. Stick around on the
channel. Um continue to come, continue
to engage. Um and may Christ Jesus
continue to draw a people to himself. Um
he is perfectly capable and able of
doing so. Um we just pray here at
Answering Adventism that he will use us
for his purposes, for his glory, knowing
that he is saving a people. He is
drawing a people to himself. We don't
have to convince people. We don't have
to uh win them with our arguments. I try
and make the best arguments that I can
obviously and seek to glorify God in the
process. But God strikes straight blows
with crooked sticks. I'm just asking to
be used by God for his purposes to
glorify himself for his kingdom to
continue to expand. And as all of his
enemies are being made a foottool, that
means time is the worst enemy of Seventh
Day Adventism. Because at some point the
organization, not all the people, the
organization itself is going to be made
a foottool underneath the feet of Jesus
Christ. Because Seventh Day Adventism is
an enemy of the true Christ, sending
people and leading people astray after
false Christ and false gospel. So again,
the call is for you to leave that come
know the truth. You can always reach out
answering adventism@gmail.com or again
over at answering adventism.com. As
always, we'll see you guys next time.
God bless.
[Music]